this is still going to go through
well I hope so because it is in the
National interest to get improvements
upon the Northern Ireland protocol to
make it easier for goods to move freely
between Great Britain and Northern
Ireland that's clearly in the interests
of the people in Northern Ireland and
also for businesses who are really
struggling at the moment in terms of
trade
how much do you know about it
we haven't seen the detail of the deal
but you know I know that often I come
into this program and tell you that I'm
going to oppose what the government's
going to do how we object to some part
of it this is just too important for
that the Good Friday agreement was
negotiated and agreed 25 years ago I
think it is one of the proudest
achievements of any political party in
the second half of the 20th century and
improvements to the Northern Ireland
protocol will help preserve the peace
that was hard won on the island of
Ireland and we're not going to do
anything to jeopardize that and we will
look to support what the Prime Minister
brings back is there any circumstances
where labor would not support this
but if it improves trade and improves
the movements of goods and services
across the Irish sea if it has the
support of the UK government and the
European Union if it Preserves on the
island of Ireland those
um the no uh cameras the no checkpoints
then then we will support it and we have
reason to believe we are understanding
it it does all those things but there
will be a soft Border in the Irish sea
well I think it improves upon where we
are now at the moment you don't have the
red and the Green Lane and you know the
red lane is for for stuff that is going
to move into the single Market but most
stuff that moves from Great Britain to
Northern Ireland isn't destined for the
single Market it's Testament destined
for the supermarket shelves and for
other businesses within uh Northern
Ireland and so look we welcome the fact
that this deal looks to simplify
um the movements of of goods across the
Irish sea um the ERG of course the
European research Group which uh you
know right-wing back benches as part of
the conservative party May well decide
that this is not a deal that they want
to support because the dup Jim great
East party do not like it
um it looks as though potentially labor
could get it over the line for the
government well we've said that the
Prime Minister shouldn't worry about the
Malcolm tents on his own back benches
and we will ensure that he has the votes
to get this through but I don't want to
jump the gun we haven't seen this deal
we don't know how the dup he and others
in the conservative party are going to
respond the best thing would be to have
cross-party support from right across
the political Spectrum for this dealer
and I hope that the Prime Minister can
secure that yeah um do you think there
should be or will be a vote in the House
of Commons I think there will be and I
think there should be
um as does that have to be rather I
don't think there has to be but I think
that it would make sense to give
legitimacy to something that the the
Prime Minister can say this is one a
majority and I believe that he will win
a big majority for it because labor is
lending our votes on this occasion uh to
the government what does it mean what
difference does it make to the people of
Great Britain if this deal does or
doesn't go ahead
well we are all part of the United
Kingdom and the citizens of Northern
Ireland are citizens of the whole United
Kingdom but they're not part of Great
Britain which is why I made this the
specific point yeah well look what
happens to people in different parts of
the country matters to me because I'm a
citizen of the United Kingdom and I care
about people wherever they live in in
the UK but also we've got loads of
businesses fantastic businesses in Great
Britain who do an awful lot of trade in
Northern Ireland and also we benefit
from things that are produced in
Northern Ireland that come into the rest
of the UK so this is good for the whole
of the United Kingdom if we can make the
improvements that um the government have
been trying to secure everyone's totally
excited um today we've been here before
though haven't we
of we've been round and round in circles
for years okay I mean I bet you've lost
count of the number of times you're
spoken about the Northern Ireland uh
protocol and look some of this comes
back to the fact that in 2019 the former
prime minister two prime ministers ago
or whatever Boris Johnson said uh he had
enough and ready deal he had nothing of
the sort and we're still today you know
grappling with this conundrum really but
I hope that progress now has finally
been uh made and and maybe we can stop
talking about the Northern Ireland
protocol and start talking about the
everyday issues of concern for people
both in Northern Ireland and throughout
the UK on the cost of living how to grow
our economy and how to improve our
Public Services like our schools and
hospitals okay I know the bosses um has
got another
um speech today he's acting about
talking a lot at the moment isn't he um
is how how do you make talking about the
G7 sexy to voters who you need to win
back
so last week last Thursday Kia set out
the missions that would guide the
government if he became uh prime
minister and the first of those missions
is to grow our economy to have the
highest sustained growth in the G7
because the truth is over the last
decade we've been falling behind our
neighbors and our competitors in the
growth League tables it doesn't have to
be that way I am really ambitious for
Britain I know that we've got huge
strengths but at the moment we're not
seizing the opportunities that are out
there so I want strong growth but I want
us to be catching up and excelling
against our neighbors and competitors I
think that's what most people in Britain
want they want a successful Dynamic
economy and they want to be competitive
with France and Germany the US and Italy
and Japan and and the other countries in
the G7 and today we're setting out some
of the policies that will help us to get
there and things like our green
Prosperity plans so we compete in the
industries of the future our plans to
make Britain the best place to start and
grow a business some of the reforms that
we want to see to the brexit deal to
make it easier for British businesses to
trade and to get investment into the UK
reform to business rates to help our
high streets to thrive but the key thing
about the mission that we're setting out
today on the economy is that this is
about good jobs and productivity growth
in all parts of the country it's not
good enough if it ever was just to have
growth in some Industries in some parts
of the UK this has got to be growth and
prosperity that's felt by ordinary
families and businesses right across the
United Kingdom in the meantime people
can't keep their houses warm um what
will you say to your Shadow your
opposite number the chancellor when it
comes to the budget and whether or not
he should keep the position that the
government presently have adopted to
help people with their bills in place
Bills should not be going up in April
the cost of living crisis is still very
real for people people's number one
concern at the moment and yet under the
government plans bills will go up to 3
000 pounds on average from April but
we've set out how we can keep those
bills um at an average of two and a half
thousand pounds still very high but it
means no further increase and we would
do that by properly taxing the windfall
profits the windfalls of war that the
big energy companies have made and
redirect that money to help families to
help pensioners and also to help
businesses with their energy bills and
that's the difference that a labor
government would make